- C'est ici que George Leslie
Mackay a trouvé sa vocation :u'a
tant aimé. Il est débarqué surl,
il y a 150 ans.
(en mandarin)
fondé la première université
de Taïwan en 1882, explique
fièrement un des responsables de
l'Université Aletheia, nouveau
l'origine le Collège Oxford.
"Nous voulons répandre l'esprit
du révérend Mackay, dit-il.
il voulait améliorer leur sort."
Sur le campus, la demeure dunsne
en musée. Des artefacts et
photos ornent les anciens
salons, rappel des soins
dentaires prodiguésnenenenenenes
de Taïwanais, en plus
de la fondation d'une
soixantaine d'églises.
Et là, au deuxième étage,
se trouvait la salle de lecture
l'endroit où tant de projets
sont nés
Sur l'île conservatrice
a fondé la première école pour
filles, les premiers pas vers
l'émancipation et l'égalité.
Le fils de George Mackay, lui,
en fondant une école qui a formé
un bon nombre de politnsnsns
et Taïwanais importants.
Le modeste hôpital fondé
est aujourd'hui devenu un vaste
réseau d'htatataux, maillon
important du réseau de la santé
de Taïwan.
Différent des autresvévévévévévd
Mackay a marié une Taïwanaise
et il parlait le mandarin, ce
qui a facilité son intégration
et lui a permis d'évdededededed.
Dans ce petit restaurant,
on prépan n n mets spécial
à base de brocoli, chou,
carottes et fèves vertes :
"C'est aussi ça, son héritage,
explique-t-il. Mackay a apporté
des semences et nous avons pu
découvrir ces légumentntntntntn"
C'est une histoire
qu'il aime raconter
aux clients de la cérémonie
du thé. C'es p p p p p p p p p e
son quartier historique.
Originaire de l'Ontario,
George Leslie Mackay est mort à
Il a été enterré avec sa famille
tout près des lieux historiques
qu'il a fondés à Taïwan.
Un timbre commémoratif a été
émis pour souligner les 150 anïe
à son héritage, qui a façonné
ce qu'est devenu l'île.
Ici Philippe anananc,
Radio-Canada, Taipe